[Musique]
elle s'est lancée en politique à 48 ans
sans aucune expérience mais ça ne l'a
pas empêché d'enchaîner les succès
jusqu'à être élu député en 2017 mais
pendant 6 ans elle n'a pas siégé il faut
dire qu'elle avait une bonne raison à
[Musique]
cela bonjour jeunevev DARIC bonjour
alors quand vous vous êtes engagé en
politique au côté de de François baayrou
beaucoup de gens à montmarsan dans votre
ville vous connaissez déjà mais alors
pas du tout pour vos idées politiques ou
pour un engagement politique et vous
connaissez parce que il vous voyez sur
le bord du terrain tous les dimanches au
stade montoit le club de rugby de la
ville parce que vous étiez le docteur
chargé de soigner les joueurs et on va
on va revoir d'ailleurs un extrait d'une
prise de parole de vous à cette époque
je crois que ce dont les joueurs ont
besoin surtout c'est d'être entouré
effectivement de de sentir que personne
ne baisse les bras autour
euh que de alors dans le club mais aussi
à l'extérieur du club je crois qu'il
faut sentir qu'on est soutenu par le
public qu'on est soutenu par peut-être
la ville dans laquelle on vit là quand
on vous entend à l'époque c'était une
période un peu difficile pour le club on
a l'impression que vous étiez presque
plus la psy des joueurs que que la
médecin bah écoutez les médecins ils
sont toujours là dans les clubs en
particulier pour pas que pour soigner le
physique et oui ils sont aussi là pour
soigner le moral pour écouter les
joueurs écouter quelquefis les détresses
écouter les question donc ça fait partie
du job moi j'ai fait ça de façon
bénévole pendant 10 ans en structurant
l'équipe médicale d'un club
professionnel devenu professionnel donc
c'était très passionnant et et en plus
de mon activité de médecin par ailleurs
allergologue je je faisais ça et ça a
été très passionnant et alors dans une
ville comme montmarsan j'imagine que ou
parce que faut savoir qu'à monond marçan
le rugby c'est pas rien quand même ça
compte énormément j'imagine que soigner
un peu les les héros de la ville c'est
un peu la Rome de lancement idéal quand
on veut faire de la politique écoutez
oui ça ve bon vous avez de la notoriété
ça ça aide effectivement et puis la
notoriété c'était pas que moi c'était
aussi mon mari qui était qui ancien
joueur qui n de l'quip grande figure
locale donc si vous voulez il a aussi
participé avec moi à à toute cette
aventure et où j'ai participé avec lui à
toute cette aventure et en définitive on
vous voit au milieu des joueurs ouais en
définitive oui ben ça c'est l'esprit
festif et puis c'est toujours quand on
gagne c'est une montée en Top 14 ça que
nous avions gagné contre pot d'ailleurs
en 2012 donc on était enfin moi j'étais
très heureuse François Baayou n'était
pas heureux mais moi j'étais très
heureuse François Baayou est venu vous
chercher en 2004 c'était à l'occasion
des des régionales et à l'époque il vous
a proposé d'être tête de liste de l'UDF
dans votre département des lande mais il
faut savoir qu'à l'époque vous n'aviez
jamais fait de politique vous n'aviez
même jamais mis les pieds je crois dans
une salle de meeting politique quand on
y réfléchi c'est quand même assez
incroyable qu'il vous ait fait cette
proposition pourquoi vous -il choisi
tout simplement parce qu'il cherchait
bon un profil quelqu'un qui était connu
dans sa ville qui était engagé dans le
le mouvement euh associatif et puis
voilà qui avait qui avait une profession
médecin c'est c'est souvent euh il
cherchait une femme aussi et il
cherchait surtout une femme c'est ça
donc pour être tête de liste dans les
Landes donc je devais cumuler un petit
peu tout cela et bon les choses ont fait
que nous nous sommes rencontrer et que
je n'ai pas pu résister à sa demande
vous aiez une petite notoriété liée au
rugby mais vous avez quand même été
surnommé par vos adversaires pendant
cette élection Madame X c'est vrai oui
madame X bon et puis une femme une femme
forcément ben elle sait pas faire elle a
pas de compéten si n'a jamais été là ben
elle va pas y arriver alors ça c'est ce
qui vous s'est passé pour vous 4 ans
après c'estàd que vous êtes attaqué à la
mairie de montmarsan qui était quand
même un bastion de la gauche depuis
presqueun demi-siècle aux mains du même
homme politique depuis combien depuis 24
ans 24 ans Philippe laberry et là vous
l'avez emporté contre toute attente et
après votre élection vos adversaire
était convaincu que bah vous alliez pas
réussir vous alliez démissionner c'est
vrai ça oui mais parce que très
simplement mes adversaires c'était le
Parti socialiste euh bah ils étaient
très macho il pensaiit qu'une femme ne
pouvait pas y arriver et que une femme
sans
expérience dans le domaine n'y
arriverait pas moi je dis à tous et à
toutes ceux qui veulent s'engager que
bah il faut il faut beaucoup travailler
il faut pas croire que les choses sont
arrivées comme ça donc c'est aussi
beaucoup de travail beaucoup
d'investissement C peut-être des
capacités à comprendre les situations et
à à faire les choses mais en tout cas
bien sûr que j'y suis arrivé j'ai été
réélu en 2000 en 2014 au premier tour
donc et et à quel moment vos adversaires
on ont commencé à changer de regard sur
vous ben écoutez je pense que monsieur
Emmanuelli qui était président du
conseil départemental et la figure
tutellaire du du Parti socialiste dans
l'lande euh bah a reconnu que j'avais
bien travaillé quand j'ai été
réélu au premier tour en 2014 donc que
j'ai fait mes preuves h alors il a dit
de vous elle est sans doute plus
tranchante que moi et dans la bouche
d'Henri Emmanuelli on peut se dire que
c'est un
compliment
euh je ne sais pas si c'est un
compliment oui peut-être c'est un compl
oui parce que lui il avait quand même la
réputation d'avoir un très fort
caractère et euh et c'était sa façon à
lui de faire de la politique c'est
peut-être un compliment mais je pense
que je ne fais pas de la politique comme
lui par contre vos
différen bah écoutez lui c'était un
petit peu de la coersition au niveau du
département avec de la qui existe encore
un peu hein bien qu'il ne soit plus là
de la coerition vis-à-vis des élus des
maires euh tous euh lié automatiquement
au conseil général ou au conseil
départemental aujourd'hui et ne pouvons
pas dévier des des trajectoires qui leur
été dicté moi justement c'est exactement
l'inverse c'est-à-dire que je pense que
chacun dans une démocratie à partir du
moment où il est élu il est légitime et
il peut s'exprimer et il faut que les
personnes travaillent ensemble dans une
bonne intelligence en 2017 à peine élu
député tout s accéléré pour vous et
alors là encore de façon un peu imprévue
on va dire
euh n'avait vraiment misé sur votre
entrée au gouvernement pas même vous
racontez-nous un peu l'histoire ah ben
écoutez ça j'y ai pas pensé une seconde
j'ai c'était très simple je venais
m'inscrire à l'Assemblée nationale
j'avais fait la moitié du chemin c'était
un 21 juin j'avais fait la moitié du
chemin et puis à à 13h j'ai un message
du cabinet d'Édouard Philippe qui me
demandait de passer à Matignon parce que
Édouard Philippe voulait me rencontrer
donc j'ai rencontréard Philippe et le
soir j'ai été nommé secrétaire d'État
auprès de la ministre des Armées et je
vous avoue que j'étais partie de chez
moi avec un sac à main pour la journée
et que j'ai dû voilà que j'ai dû rester
quelques jours et et tout ça est assez
était totalement imprévu et et c'était
imprévu parce qu'en fait à l'origine il
était plutôt prévu que François Baayou
et Marielle de sarnis soient au
gouvernement les choses n'ont pas pu se
faire en l'état et on a un peu
l'impression que c'est l'effet papillon
appliqué à à la politique c'est-à-dire
que
deux petits événements ont des
répercussions en chaînne et finissent
par déterminer votre propre destin pour
6 ans oui c'est mais je je reconnais
qu'il y a eu un concours de
circonstances euh un concours de
circonstances pour moi c'est
incroyable et qui m'a propulsé dans un
dégouvernement en définitive pendant 6
ans euh et bien voilà donc j'ai j'ai
donné tout ce que j'avais tout ce que je
pouvais faire et j'étais voilà à la fois
très honoré très fier de de de de servir
mon pays et aussi très concentré dans la
tâche dans le quotidien mais aussi dans
le le l'avenir qu'il faut que l'on
décine et quand on est dans un
gouvernement et je trouve bien entendu
tout cela était tout à fait passionnant
alors passionnant pendant 6 ans d'abord
vous l'avez dit secrétaire d'État auprès
de la ministre des Armées après vous
avez été ministre délégé en charge de la
mémoire et des anciens combattants puis
en charge des personnes handicapées euh
quand l'aventure a pris fin qu'est-ce
qui a dominé chez vous est-ce que il y
avait une part de frustration que ça
s'arrête de pas pouvoir aller au bout
des choses ou une part de soulagement
peut-être s il y a une fatigue accumulée
au fil du temps ni l'un ni l'autre non
euh frustration
euh peut-être parce que quand on par
exemple pour les personnes handicapées
j'ai mis en œuvre la la Conférence
nationale du handicap toutes les
annonces qui ont été faites par le
Président de la République et maintenant
il faut les décliner sur les 5 ans à
venir mais en fait je me dis que bon
c'est bien la la feuille de route elle a
été écrite et financée
donc le plus important je ne sais pas
parce qu'il faut le mettre en œuvre
après c'est ça le plus important dans
les politiques mais au moins voilà nous
avons fait ce travail et ensuite fatigué
oui c'est usant c'est usant d'être dans
les gouvernements de faire beaucoup de
déplacements voilà les choses sont
tuantes mais bon donc ni l'un ni l'autre
je crois que j'ai pris ça comme je
prends toutes les choses dans ma vie je
me dis que j'ai eu la chance de faire ce
que j'ai fait et que maintenant j'ai
d'autres objectifs alors vous avez
visiblement pris beaucoup de plaisir à
la fois dans vos fonctions de maire puis
de membres du gouvernement tout ça c'est
l'exécutif aujourd'hui vous êtes à
l'assemblée du côté du pouvoir
législatif est-ce que ça correspond
autant à votre tempérament beaucoup
moins h mais est-ce que ça vous euh
beaucoup moins beaucoup moins dans
l'exécutif est très passionnant euh
beaucoup moins mais en définitive ce qui
peut être intéressant c'est la bataille
politique parce que c'est là qu' elle se
joue euh et la bataille politique
aujourd'hui elle est rude elle est rude
parce que nous sommes en majorité dites
relatives et puis que nous avons des
oppositions extrêmes qui sont
excessivement virulentes qui sont très
euh même très violente à mon avis dans
leurs expressions euh et je crois qu'il
faut pas se laisser faire il faut pas se
laisser faire parce que d'abord c'est
bien injuste bien entendu et ensuite je
pense que dans ces moments troublés la
France aurait besoin d'un peu plus de
modération que de radicalité et de
propos violents donc je il ne faut pas
se laisser faire et moi je vous prê à
mener cette bataille politique à
l'Assemblée il y a un sujet dont on n
pas encore parlé c'est votre attachement
aux traditions locales du Sud-Ouest ça
peut être la feria mais pas seulement il
y a aussi la défense de la corrida le
gavage des oies des canards les chasses
locales vous comprenez que que ça puisse
faire débat aujourd'hui tous ces sujets
là dans dans la société je comprends que
tous tout puisse faire débat ce que j'ai
plus de mal à comprendre c'est une
espèce
d'acharnement sur ben tout simplement
les habitants de nos régions pour vous
ça cible les habitants oui bien sûr bien
sûr euh ils sont discriminés on les
prend pour des ploues excusez-moi pour
des gens qui n'ont pas de cervelle avec
une cruauté bon c'est pas ça du tout
nous nous sommes notre notre coin est un
un pays de cocagne avec ses traditions
certes avec ses modernités aussi avec
ses évolution également et je je
m'inscris en faux quand on décrit voilà
la façon dont sont décrit les choses et
puis de faut fiche la paix aux gens vous
avez peur que ça nourrisse un vote
populiste d'interdire la corria par
exemple non mais le le c'est c'est une
accumulation si vous voulez des
accumulations d'interdictions qui ou de
de de projets d'interdiction sur des
pratiques locales qui sont en fait tout
simplement des pratiques traditionnelles
ou des pratiques culturelles locales les
cultures locales il faut les maintenir
si on fait tous la même chose si on
pense tous la même chose si on mange
tous la même chose et bien le monde
n'aura plus beaucoup d'intérêt on va
passer à notre quiz à présent donc je
vais commencer des phrases vous allez
devoir les les
terminer on y va redevenir maire de
monde Marsan en 2026 c'est quelque chose
de possible que vous envisagez donc
sérieusement pourquoi pas très bien
c'est noté j'ai l'air auoster mais en
fait je le suis pas du tout je me mar
comme comme disait j un Oster qui se
marre et je trouve qu'on se marre pas
assez d'ailleurs ici enfin Jaune et Noir
sont nos couleurs oui vos supportes sont
là debout oui voilà montmarçan est dans
nos cœurs bah c'est l'hyne suppor seront
là jusqu'au bout on voit la la réponse
sffichée c'est c'est l'hyne du club du
Stade Montois voilà vous y êtes tout
enfin tous les weekends non mais à
chaque chaque match vous y allez bah
j'essis mais pendant mes 6 ans
gouvernement j'ai loupé beaucoup de
match heureusement RRA maintenant je
rraper merci beaucoup je v la politique
merci à
[Musique]
vous